once we get to the final two which is
unpredictable to predict uh we then have
the
the idea the notion
of this being quite an open race going
into the hustins around the country and
i remember covering uh the race between
jeremy hunt and boris johnson uh back in
2019 and both men put in a huge amount
of effort
but really it was cosmetic in that boris
johnson was pretty much always nailed on
to take uh and win uh the party
membership and win that race and he run
it really decisively whereas this time
around it really does seem to be far
wider open in terms of who might make
the final two and then who
might win the competition
uh well last year we're talking there
beth we have got the first live pictures
in of the committee room where we're
going to be hearing the announcements
from sir graham brady of the 1922
committee the first round of the ballot
in the conservative leadership contest
of course electing the next leader but
also the next prime minister as well and
you can see some people just
the first people to take their seats in
that room now are starting to make their
way in about five minutes or so until
we're expecting that announcement which
we'll of course bring you straight away
in the meantime bear i just wonder what
you make
of the
i guess the tone of the campaign so far
all the mps that i've interviewed today
have said that they want to make sure
that um actually i'm just going to pause
there because we can see penny mordance
penny how confident are you
smiles from penny mordance they're
flanked by andrea ludson as she walks
through central lobby's smiles from
penny morden as well perhaps
unsurprisingly it does feel like she is
getting some campaign momentum doesn't
it let's get back to you now beth and
beth it's interesting that's the second
time we've seen uh penny morden uh walk
through at central lobby uh perhaps a
sign of someone who might be quite
confident i guess going into the first
round
backers and she is with rishi sunnah the
only one that's officially gone over the
30
30 vote threshold of public backers so
she is now firmly into second place she
had a successful launch uh this morning
and you've seen the polling this
afternoon uh putting her as the party
member's favorite and now the bookies
favorite so for penny morden as i was
saying that the dark horse the rather
unknown in this race this has been a
very very positive uh day for her and
her team but let's see uh where liz
trust comes out too she will come out no
doubt fighting uh tomorrow and also
there's still big cabinet uh backers
still to declare and uh that will be
watched with interest too but in the
imminent moments what we will be looking
at um is we'll be looking to see as sam
was saying who is in the drop zone when
you look at the
publicly declared uh backers of mps
nadim sahari and jeremy hunt both on 14
supporters swella braverman on 16 uh
kemi badanok on 24 so we're looking to
see with those four uh who who will make
it through i think it's pretty uh nailed
on to be honest that jeremy hunt uh
probably won't uh make it uh someone
close to him saying to me the numbers
were looking pretty dicey for jeremy
hump but that perhaps as i said earlier
an opportunity
for penny mordant because it was she uh
who supported jeremy humpback in 2019
and you were saying sophie about andrew
led some dame andrew led some former
cabinet minister uh going through uh
central lobby with penny morden uh
andrea ledson
introduced penny mordant on stage today
just as penny mordant introduced jeremy
hunt back in 2019 when he was the guy
that went through to the final two and
in that run-off with boris johnson so
you know i would suggest i would hope or
expect for penny warden's sake that if
she backed him back then once he drops
out of the race will he come in behind
her and can he bring other supporters
with him
i guess that's it isn't it because the
people who drop out of the race is
interesting not just because they're no
longer in it but of course that question
as you were saying there beth about
where their supporters go all eyes on
the 1922 committee which is filling up
people fanning themselves um i guess uh
beth what are your sort of predictions
as we
wait for that result it's now five
o'clock so we're expecting it at any
moment
well i i mean my i hate making
predictions in politics uh because it's
so changeable but look i mean i think
it's pretty clear that uh we're gonna
have four to five uh people nailed on to
go through and it's a question of uh who
drops out
and then once that happens how quickly
the race tightens the thing i'm looking
at in the next couple of days is how
quickly or does it does the right of the
party coalesce around liz truss as their
favorite candidate and can penny mordant
keep momentum or will people that don't
want liz trust then move to rishi sunak
that's that's what i'm interested in
they're coming in
or you can see there the grain brady
let's have a listen he is about to come
in and announce the results of the first
round of voting in the vote to be the
next leader of the conservative party
and also the next prime minister let's
listen in it's what i prepared earlier
good evening
good evening i can now announce the
result
of the ballot held
this afternoon uh i'll
read the names of the candidates in
alphabetical order with the number of
votes secured
by that candidate
uh bad enoch
40.
braverman
32
hunt 18
mordant 67
sunak 88
trus 50
toucandat
37 zahawi 25.
therefore under the rules that we
agreed for this ballot
uh two candidates will be
eliminated
jeremy hunt and nadim zahawi the others
are all able to go forward to the second
ballot which takes place tomorrow thank
you very much
because we've got votes coming at uh 17
minutes personally three votes it's time
for the cameras to leave the room uh and
we will start our hustings at the end of
the last of the divisions thank you
we're gonna have to win we'll do that
then as well
well they are the results uh two
candidates eliminated jeremy hunts who
managed to get 18 votes and redeems the
highway on 25 and that means that six of
the eight candidates progress richie
sunak topping the poll with 88 votes
followed by penny mordent
in second place on 67 and liz trust in
third on 50. but let's bring in our
political editor beth rigby beck what do
you make of it
well that is an interesting result
sophie in that there are six going
through to the next round and i think
there's an expectation that maybe
sweller bravo man wouldn't make it
through
but anyway look you've got six out of
the eight going through what's
interesting about that is look at rishi
sunak 88 his team are going to be
delighted with that what that shows is
the momentum for the former chancellor
there and then penny mordant coming in
on
67 when she had publicly declared 34. i
mean she's nearly doubled her numbers
there she will be delighted as well
what's interesting about liz trust there
on 50 look at how on the right of the
party the vote is still splitting you've
got liz truss on 50 kemi badanok on 40.
sawela bravaman on 32. you'll remember
pretty patel didn't want to enter the
race in the end or chose not to because
she was worried about the split on the
right of the party and i think that
split on the right is maybe holding eliz
truss back in terms of those votes and
finally
you've got tom tuggenheart he is the
choice of the one nation group of
conservatives coming in on 37 having had
publicly declared
22 votes now what's interesting about
tom tuggenheart when you uh look at
penny mordant
is that she is positioning herself as a
conviction brexiteer and a one-nation
conservative so she's clearly aiming to
try and take the tugan hat votes even
when he finally has to concede or gets
voted out and also those 18 votes for
jeremy hunt as i was saying he was the
guy that backed well she was the woman
that backed him back in 2019 i expect he
will fall into her camp now so the race
really on and actually at the moment um
the stop sonic campaign uh isn't doing
very well in terms of the right of the
party uh being split across those three
candidates trust badanok and bravoman
and how might that
wash out
in the ballots tomorrow but for sunuk
and morden they will be absolutely
delighted i imagine uh with their
showing in the first round
and beth i'm interested to know your
thoughts you were speaking before about
the three candidates um richie sunak
penny morden and liz trust who perhaps
you have a sense they have the momentum
pulling away slightly from the others
how important is that race for second
place with penny morden on 67 votes
compared to 50 for liz trust well sophie
that for me that that race is is the
most interesting and actually the one
everyone's talking about when you you
know you you catch up with the campaigns
and you talk to mps because if you're
rishi sonak and you are out front as he
is uh you you've got to start to try and
think who could i
who my best place to beat
in the final hustins with party members
and at the moment when you're looking at
the polling of yougov members and the
bookies penny mordan is not the person
that rishi sanat will want to face in
the final round in fact one of his camp
or mp supporters told me that yesterday
they were quite explicit about that so
what we're going to get on to soon is as
this shakes out and as this contest
really begins to narrow down you've got
to have a look at how much momentum has
rishi sunup got and can he afford to
start lending votes from his campaign to
others in order to perhaps block penny
morden now his camp insists to me that
that is not
what they're doing that this race is too
wild and wide and it's all focused on
just give getting rishi sunak as many
votes as they can but as it gets to the
final stages which could come as early
as monday it could be decided it could
run on to wednesday next week that will
certainly be
the considerations that some of the
operations behind these candidates will
be making i remember back in 2019
when we knew that boris johnson was
going to get over the finish line and
really in terms of the other two there
was michael gove another brexiteer there
was jeremy hunt a remainer turned
brexiteer and it ended up with i think
jeremy hunt getting 75 votes and michael
gove getting 73 and that was widely
discussed afterwards the way in which uh
the johnson camp had helped uh slightly
stump michael gove by lending votes to
jeremy hunt to get him over the line and
not michael gove still boris johnson's
arch enemy out of the race
also beth it's interesting to reflect as
well on a number of candidates who are
still in it there were eight candidates
in the race at the beginning of the day
there are still six uh in it as well uh
only jeremy hunt and deem sahari
falling at the first hurdle do you think
that's going to impact the tone of the
race going forward
i i do think that's interesting i mean
there was a discussion at the beginning
of this when boris johnson
was forced to to concede that he
couldn't carry on as prime minister on
thursday last week immediately we got on
to how quickly are they going to be able
to whittle down the candidates will the
party try and do this from reset before
recess and then there was a discussion
the party about uh thresholds that they
would set in order to try and whittle
this race down quickly you know we
started off with 11 uh runners and
riders with pretty patel a potential
12th and you know after the first ballot
we're down to six so people might have
expected that uh to be slightly lower
but they didn't have as big a threshold
as higher threshold i should say as
perhaps people thought uh might happen
at the beginning there was some talk for
before the number 9020 decided the rules
for example that mps would need 10 of
the parliamentary party uh to get past
uh the first ballot that would have been
36 mps now if they'd applied that rule
bravo man would have sweller bradman
would have automatically been out and
tom tougenhart would have just scraped
through but they didn't decide to do
that i think there was a sort of view
from mps as well like we want our
candidates to have a run at it
but let's see what happens tomorrow and
how how it shakes out but six at this
stage is that's quite a lot of runners
and riders and as i said one of the
interesting things when you look at that
list
is how the right of the party really has
not settled on one candidate yet
really interesting to hear your analysis
uh beth will have more from beth as the
evening wears on and we digest uh the
first indication we've had of where
conservative mps are at rishi sunak
topping the pole in the first ballot
with 88 votes penny morden in second
place with 67 and liz trust in third on
50 meanwhile nadim zahawi and jeremy
hunt are
out while the conservative mps have had
their say but after it's whittled down
over the next week and next week as well
a yoga poll of 879 party members has put
penny morden way ahead with 27
of party members saying that they would
like to see her as taking over from
boris johnson as the next prime minister
and this matters of course uh because it
is uh
members who are going to be voting uh
after the mps have had their say well
let's go to uh sam coats now shall we
our deputy political editor to try and
reflect uh on that uh result only two
eliminated was she seen like as expected
topping the polls but penny morden
really it feels as if she's racing up
the inside track to come to second place
look as we've been saying afternoon it's
the penny morden's numbers that are
clicking up and and it's really
extraordinary she just launched her
campaign this morning as one of her team
was just reflecting to me they didn't
have the kind of infrastructure that the
richardson campaign the liz trust
campaign uh have had and yet here she is
in second place poised potentially to
enter the ballot uh in under a week's
time
and
this despite not being in the cabinet
not having spent a great deal of time in
the cabinet
and both of her rivals currently or
formerly holding
main drivers holding the great offices
of state when i look at those numbers
that were on the screen a moment a
moment ago
uh
two things strike me first of all you
can see uh the number of rishi sooner
votes going up but i couldn't tell you
looking at that screen uh those those
results exactly who's going to be in the
final two why
because the number that surprised me the
most in that result was liz truss
liz trust got 50 she's one of the two
big figures in this race and she ended
up with a lower number i think than many
would have expected
you would have expected potentially
liz trust to be within single digits of
penny morton but no she was down she was
down at 50 votes so we're having this
conversation uh about who's going to be
in the final uh in the final two liz
trusts lower than you think but but the
other thing that means that you you
can't say what's going to happen in this
race is that um richard's united
currently on 88 uh decla uh mps in that
in that ballot but the question is how
many other people then come behind him
who aren't already supporters of rishi
sooner how much higher can he take that
is it the case that the bravaman uh
votes and the um uh the kenny badenock
votes and some of the two compact fates
all go behind liz trust or penny morgan
and actually over time people are able
to overtake what she said
everything to play for
liz trust doing slightly less better
than i expected penny morden storming
ahead and she has the endorsement uh and
the support uh of the membership by
double-digit margins according to that
yougov poll that we released just after
lunch and you've just got that sense
that this race is very very live indeed
i think we can actually bring in the
yoga poll that you were talking about
now or shall we because that poll it was
a poll of 879 party members and it did
put
penny mordant uh well ahead to be honest
of her rivals you can see there the
question asked was which of any of the
following candidates do you most want to
replace boris johnson penny mordent in
front on 27
uh kemi badanok in second place on 15
with rishi sunak and liz trusts in third
place on 13 and it does feel as if this
potentially affected the momentum of the
race yeah so this is what happens in the
final round with the
tory members there are two big things
two big stories that you're looking at
on your screen the first is the momentum
for penny mordant and the other is that
pennywise hasn't been at the top table
of british politics for that long
long
but the number of people who say they
don't know about this in this race is
very very small if you put together
don't knows and not sure uh and uh none
of the above then actually what you're
having is a clear message from the tory
membership as david davis has been
arguing today effectively looking like
they're making the argument for a clean
start they don't want rishi sooner he's
been in boris johnson's cabinet he's
been at his side for much of the
premiership they don't want liz trust
who's incorporated so many uh of those
uh boris johnson backers jacob rees-mogg
nadine uh nadine doris who've been
dominating their airwaves punching the
lights out of rishi zunak they don't
seem to want either of those they seem
to want a little bit of a clean start
that's why on every measure whenever you
go head-to-head according to this yougov
poll uh
penny morden beats all of the potential
uh rivals the only question at the
moment seems to be to me who would be in
the final final two potentially with
penny morton is it rishi sunak who's got
the momentum at the moment but i suspect
i suspect that there is some sort of
questions about how many of the people i
haven't declared uh how many of people
uh who uh whose first choice drops out
ends up behind him and then how many add
on to lose trust is surprisingly low
number interesting stuff i'm going to
come back to in a minute sam but i think
we can just bring in
uh some of the reaction that we're
getting from some of the candidates
we've got some tweets that have been
coming in in reaction to the
results so far firstly from tom tuganat
who of course managed to stay in the
race he tweeted to say this is a
fantastic result i'm delighted to be
going through to the next round with the
momentum we need to change this country
for the better tom tugan at picking up
37 votes and therefore crossing the 30
vote
threshold that was needed we've also had
a reaction from liz trust from a
spokesperson from this trust who said
now is the time for colleagues to unite
behind the candidate who will cut taxes
deliver the real economic change we need
from day one and ensure that putin
loses in ukraine
they go on to say that liz has the
experience to deliver the benefits of
brexit from day one grow our economy and
support
working families so a bit of reaction
from some of the candidates apologies
you're gonna hear the bell there's lots
of votes going on so we are going to be
hearing that bell ringing a fair bit
we're joined now by two people who just
voted in the uh leadership contest thank
you very much for being uh with us david
davis and daniel thank you very much for
being with us can you first tell us he
voted for one
i voted for jeremy hunt
he's a friend i like him very much i
think he has a lot of experience in
government
a very credible former foreign secretary
obviously i'm very disappointed
that he he's been knocked out
but i've been very impressed over the
last few days with penny morden she has
performed very well on television and in
the hustlings i'm going back at 5 15 to
hear the hustings but at the moment a
lot of my association senior officers
and members are saying back penny morgan
uh one of them could be um
standing beside you as well uh you of
course have been uh supporting uh
pennyward and what did you make of the
result well it's a very good result for
us i mean always these early results
with a large number are spread out but
we're much closer to rishi sunak than we
thought we'd be
we've done better than our estimate
it reinforces the the polls that you've
been talking about today
uh as daniel says ordinary members and
officers and associations all saying
that they want to reset and what and
that's that's what came out of the polls
what's looking like uh in in this uh in
this set of numbers is that the
parliamentary party wants a reset too so
that's good for us i'm very interested
in because obviously all eyes are on the
people who come up top but actually what
is also interesting is what happens to
the vote to the people who are
eliminated jeremy hunt obviously uh one
person who didn't make the cut this time
around did you always suspect that penny
morton was going to pick up your vote or
has something happened uh more recently
to make him change your mind i think i
can only say what i said before which is
i have been
very very surprised at how
well she has run the campaign how
effective she's been at the hustings
and on the media
and more and more of my members are
sending me clips of her performance
when she eviscerated
mrs rainer
on the debate she's really strong
strong conviction
good personality and i think she would
make a very credible prime minister
we've been through a bit of a bruising
and we need to come together as a party
and i think she she certainly has the
attributes to bring the conservative
party together yes i'm just going to
pause you for a minute because we do
have some reaction from jeremy hunt he's
tweeted to say i want to thank my
incredible team of loyal and talented
supporters who put their faith in me
it's become obvious to me you only get
one big shot at this and i had mine in
2019 he goes on to say nevertheless it's
clear that our party has an exciting
future with the amazing array of talent
on offer in this contest and i feel
confident we're on track to win back
trust
can i just say that's the characteristic
of the man
he's a really
nice gentleman and uh it shows
do you think how do you think the tone
about debate has been so far well
there's been a bit of black propaganda
of course but actually it is now
evolving down to real arguments about
policy i mean all of the people who are
staying in the race have been pitching
their policy line now to be frank has
been a bit of a dutch auction over tax
cuts for a lot of them and i think
that'll favor my candidate because penny
today and that astounding launch laid
out a real program for growth the real
program for cutting inflation a real
program for taking our country on so i
think the debate actually is turning
into a healthy debate about what we want
for the country and that's a good thing
it's interesting isn't it because i
guess rishi sunex supporters would argue
that he is the person who at least is
setting out a realistic vision and
perhaps others have thrown around shall
we say some unfunded tax cuts or tax
cuts that seem to be funded by cutting a
few civil servants here and there which
won't obviously go anywhere near
raising the kind of money that you need
i mean would you say that that's
something that at least we should see
now is trying to i guess a bit of
physical discipline into the debate what
i would say is what was also written in
the times newspaper today which is how
incredibly diverse and effective the
candidates are i'm very proud that we've
got such high quality candidates coming
through to the leader of the
conservative party and mr sunak is
credible as are many of the others but i
think as i said before you have to
listen to what your association members
are saying
and some of some of your officers
running your local party it seems to me
that amongst the membership that's
ultimately going to decide the outcome
of this
it seems to me that conservative party
members are moving towards penny more
one final question to you david davis
we've seen an extraordinary few weeks
and months with people
resigning over boris johnson's actions
others backing him
penny morden was a bit like a submarine
she was pretty quiet wasn't she do you
think that could come across as being a
bit tactical at a time when other people
were at least making a stand for their
opinion on boris johnson did she have
one eye on the leadership contest no i
think i think it's almost the reverse of
that
when i was an accountable penny i've
already said to you earlier that she was
tough and fierce and brave and bluntly i
think that's one of the reasons that
boris didn't put her in his cabinet and
she'd been in this cabin i think you
might have heard a lot more but as a
junior minister it's ten times as tough
to make an impact on that she's somebody
who's got a very very strong sense of
moral value
and that's already showing through today
okay thank you both very much uh thank
you for letting us know how you voted
today interesting stuff well there you
go just two mps of course but it does
feel as though penny morden is the
candidate who's had more momentum today
than the others she has managed to
squeeze liz trust
into third place taking second place on
that first ballot behind rishi sunak we
can go now to our chief political
correspondent john craig who's just over
the road from us in port culler's house
john what are mps telling you
well obviously attention now focuses on
what happens next and to help us i'm
joined by uh a uh hope he doesn't mind a
grande a veteran of these contests a
charles walker former uh vice chair of
the 1922 committee you of course were
the returning officer in 2019 uh when
boris johnson and jeremy hunt went
through to the final two uh just remind
us who you've supported in this first
round i supported penny mordent and why
was that i think she's fantastic i think
she's the reset we need
i'm not a very good talking head of
promoting candidates because i've never
done it before but she's just got that x
factor i think
and what do you think her 67 votes says
about where we are now well that was a
good result i thought that was a good
result with with eight candidates and
they all did they all did pretty well i
mean we lost two
we lost jeremy and nadine so there's 43
votes up for grabs in the next round so
i i think the big question for the 1922
committee this evening will be where
they set the cutoff threshold for the
next round this round it was 30. i
reckon it will settle somewhere between
40 and 50 for the next round why do you
think that uh sergey and brady didn't
announce that just now because on monday
evening when he announced the rules uh
he and the 22 and the tory board did say
in the first round it's 30. why has he
not announced it just now because you've
got to see how many get through
if if four are dropped out or two had
dropped out one had dropped out that
that changes the mathematics you see so
you've got to understand how many free
votes there are and what the other
remaining six candidates scored so
that's a decision best taken once you
know what the first round of results are
you take it at each step at each stage
but we do know now we know that uh nadim
zahaway who got 25 has dropped out and
jeremy hunt
18. so there's only 43 votes to play for
i'm surprised that uh sir graham hasn't
announced the threshold they haven't
worked it out well it was only 15
minutes ago that the results were
announced give them a break yeah but
voting finished at half past three yeah
but they've got to sit down and work it
out they've got to sit down and work it
out and of course it's also the case
that occasionally a candidate drops out
that's the other reason so in 2019
although matt hancock i recall made a
threshold he decided to withdraw so
you've got to talk to the candidates
after the result is announced and make
sure that all six want to carry on
and i suspect they will in this case or
whether one or two want to drop out at
this stage so it takes a little bit of
time so you think the threshold in round
two
needs to be between somewhere between 40
and 50. i mean i don't think it but i i
mean i i think that's where it might
settle somewhere between 40 and 50. i'm
not on the 22 anymore i believe i
believe that's where it will settle
somewhere believe somewhere between 40
and 50 but of course i could be wrong on
that well that would make people like
suella bravo and only 32
tom tougenhart 37 possibly kemi badanok
40 the most vulnerable the ones who are
left wouldn't it um
do you think some of the candidates will
drop out um
i don't no because it was quite an
aggressive threshold for the first round
it was it was over 30 for the first
round in 2019 it was 17. so i think if
you've scored 32 in your zoella there's
43 votes out there you're going to say
right i think i can go and get eight of
those or 10 of those or maybe 15 of
those so i'm going to carry on
how significant is it you think that mr
sunak is ahead by 21 ahead of uh penny
morden 88 to 67. does that matter you're
supporting um uh penny mordant i mean
some i spoke to a cabinet minister who
said to me penny morden won't pick up
that many more because the candidates
drop out who drop out we'll go to trust
and sooner what do you think about that
oh there's all sorts of kidology people
love to to speculate look i'm really
pleased penny is performing well i hope
she makes it to the final two but look
i'm not going to be distraught if if she
gets there and rishi wins for example
because i'm a conservative i want my
candidate to win i really do but that's
why i'm supporting her but we've got a
lot of good candidates in this contest
and first and foremost i'm a member of
of the conservative party then secondly
at the moment i'm a member of the penny
morden team but i want a good contest
okay thank you very much i'm sure we
will get a good contest so there we have
from someone who has been a returning
officer
the prediction that the threshold next
time will be somewhere between 40 and 50
to get into round three sophie
it will be really interesting to see
that the thresholds make all the
difference don't they john craig there
are reporting for us in port color's
house
well i'm here in central lobby with our
deputy political editor uh sam coats
it's the first time we've actually seen
real numbers we've had a lot of words
but now we've finally got a sense i
guess mps we have to put their money
where their mouth is what do you make of
the numbers we've seen um so i think the
most important thing to tell viewers is
when you look at those numbers on the
screen at the moment what's the what's
the hurdle they've got got to get down
to now the whole job of the mps rounds
to get this down to the last two
in order to do that you basically need
to get a third of the vote plus one in
other words when you look at the numbers
on the screen
each contender is looking at getting to
119
in order to get into the last two so if
you look at that richie's two next
number but richardson is just 31 votes
away from
uh getting in the final two and that
could come from some of the tom tugan
hat votes perhaps perhaps some of those
voting uh for kenny badenock so perhaps
he's got the smallest distance but it's
not that big a distance to travel 31
votes penny borden well she's got to get
52 votes in order to get uh into the
final two uh liz trust as i was saying
earlier slightly surprising down on 50
votes
so there you've got uh 79 votes
effectively needing to get there so
that's the margin 31 votes is all the
rishi needs to get to be the first
person in the final two the question can
he do it given all of the criticism he's
getting from others in this race it is
all about momentum isn't it uh sam thank
you very much uh indeed sam coats there
underlined that the winning line is 119
votes there'll be more voting going on
uh tomorrow but certainly we are at a
stage now where two people have been
eliminated today deems the zahawi and
jeremy hunt all eyes now on where
their support goes well joining us now
to discuss this is teresa villas who is
supporting rasheed cena why did you
decide to give your vote to mr sooner
because i think he's got the experience
the ability and the plan to get us
through these difficult economic times
we're going through and i also believe
speaking as someone as a so-called
brexit spartan who
very much supported our vote to leave
that um he will take for the north
atlanta protocol and safeguard our union
with northern ireland which is also
crucial it's interesting to hear you
know from you as someone who did back
brexit that you're going for richie
sooner coming on speaking to sauelo
brogan earlier he said she thinks she's
the only authentic brexiteer in the race
david davis is going for uh penny morden
why do you think will she soon act as a
person who can deliver on brexit
he voted for it in the referendum at a
stage when he'd only been in parliament
a year or so that would have been a
tough decision to take he believes in it
he's actually been implementing it with
his financial services reforms so that
uh on areas like solvency ii we take our
own decisions rather than accepting
eu laws
and
you know fruit of all to make a
successor brexit we have to make a
success of the economy and he showed
during the pandemic that
he's calming a crisis and he can deliver
huge schemes like the furlough scheme
and he's the one who can help us get
through this inflation spike i just
wonder are you worried that some of the
momentum of rishi's scenic's campaign
seems to be seeping away we have a
yougov poll out today and polar party
members have put penny morden by far in
a way the most popular candidate among
members and actually in a two-way
run-off that rishi sunak only managed to
beat nadeem sahib
well richie actually outpolls all the
other contenders when you when you go to
members of the general public i think
he's made a really good start today but
absolutely this is going to be a close
contrast we've got some truly excellent
leadership contenders um but i i i will
be strongly campaigning for rishi and i
think he's got a very good chance of
winning all eyes as well i guess on the
race for second place he's far away
above the others in terms of declared mp
backers and also in the first round
there and it feels like there's quite an
interesting tussle going on between
penny morden and liz trust would you say
there there certainly is yes um
as ever these contests are highly
unpredictable which is why the the
phones will be ringing hot
this evening and over the next few hours
before the the next round and i guess
everyone's going to be tapping up those
supporters from dean zahavi and jeremy
hoffman trying to sway them over
into the different camps there will be
no escaping for for those people on
those teams they will be very very
popular this evening i just wonder do
you think that there is an issue for
rishi sooner where if you're someone an
mp or indeed a party member who doesn't
like boris johnson you think well this
is a man who was behind beside boris
johnson throughout the pandemic he was
his chancellor until very recently but
then if you're a pro boris johnson
supporter you think this is someone who
resigned against boris johnson do you
think that's a difficult place for
richie sooner to be pitching himself
what is more important i think is that
experience as chancellor of the
exchequer i think it is much harder for
someone to to step up from a lower
profile more junior level and that's one
of the things that gives me confidence
that ritchie is the right man to become
our prime minister he he can hit the
ground running
because of that experience in government
and also
experience of the severe crisis that we
faced in the kobet pandemic but then
again he also has a record to be judged
on they could be small but i think
described him as a socialist chancellor
he has a record to be judged on but that
includes
you know acting phenomenally fast during
the pandemic with the furlough scheme
that includes delivering real brexit
regulatory reform and that includes
cutting taxes yes overall the tax burden
is higher than we'd like it to be
in order to fund
the kobe backlog in the nhs but he is
determined to
get us through this inflation crisis and
get our taxes down how difficult
position do you think the conservative
party is in right now
you've had the first ever prime minister
to be fined in office you've had of
course going through a leadership
election where with the greatest will in
the world people will be trying to tear
strips off other candidates as that race
hots up are you concerned about the
standing that the conservatives are
currently in the general public
the events that led to the resignation
of boris johnson have been deeply
damaging
for the government and the conservative
party that's why we must use this
leadership race to start to restore that
trust to demonstrate that we're going to
be delivering on the issues that matter
to people i think much good work was
done
by the outgoing prime minister but uh
there is there is a great deal more work
to do but unfortunately i believe i have
to go and vote right now so i may have
to dash off into the division lobby okay
uh that sounds very fair enough thank
you very much for coming on the program
to read the videos there well that bell
keeps running in that's because there
are actually lots of votes going on
tonight so our mps are darting in and
out at central lobby i can see teresa
villas actually running away there to
make sure she gets there on time well i
have a statement that i can bring you uh
right now from nadim zahawi he of course
was one of the candidates the two
candidates to be knocked out
this round after only polling at 25 mps
to support him
he has given a statement to say i love
my country and i love my party i'm a
proud briton and a proud conservative
with humility and a sense of duty i
accepted the position of chancellor the
exchequer because i wanted to serve my
country and the british people i stood
for the position of leader of the
conservative party because i have a
passionate vision for the united kingdom
that i want to see one more ability
skills and productivity are the key to
achieving success and where there is
opportunity for all i came to this
country with very little he goes on to
say
and
he has given me everything i've lived
the british dream i was driven to enter
politics to help
others he then goes on to effectively
accept his defeat he says clearly my
part in the contest has now ended my
priority is my work as chancellor of the
exchequer he then goes on to say i don't
intend to make any further intervention
but i wish all the candidates in the
leadership contest the very best of luck
so that was the statement from
nadim zahawi the man who many saw is one
of the favorites going into this
competition but he didn't manage to
clear the required 30 mps coming out to
support him he says interestingly that
he isn't going to be making any further
intervention in the contest in other
words he isn't going to be endorsing
another candidate instead he is going to
be focusing on his work as chancellor
but of course i guess those phones are
going to be ringing for all those 25 mps
who backed nadim zahawi as the other
camps trying to hoover them up well
let's take a look now at what happened
in the house of commons today at prime
minister's questions it was only at 12
o'clock but it feels like a lifetime ago
already and it was all about the current
resident of 10 downing street with boris
johnson facing mps for the first time
since announcing his resignation our
political correspondent ali fortescue
analyses what happened in pmq's
unwrapped
a week since the undignified collapse of
boris johnson's government he was back
in the chamber for his first prime
minister's questions since agreeing to
go but first there was an unusual and
chaotic start
neil hamby i am now naming you and kenny
mccaskill to leave this chamber should i
just deal with them deal with them
say them out sergeant get them out
two mps thrown out for protesting in the
chamber when it did come to the prime
minister he was perhaps not his usual
buoyant self so soon after being ousted
by his own party but he was colorful in
his criticism of labor
i think if possible mr speaker he's
referring not to me uh but uh some of
the eight brilliant candidates who are
currently buying uh for my job
any one of them would wipe the floor
with captain crasher rooney's snooze
fest
and after a few weeks time
that is exactly what they will do they
will unite around the winner and do just
that
and the prime minister was definitely in
legacy making mode
and it's perfectly true it's perfectly
true that i leave not at a time of my
choosing and i will be leaving mr
speaker
i will be leaving soon with
my head held high
with the leadership race underway labour
were keen to broaden their criticism
onto the man who may well replace boris
johnson
i really am going to miss this weekly
nonsense from him
let's move on from his current
chancellor to his former chancellor
last week he resigned
yesterday
he claimed his big plan
is to rebuild the economy now even the
prime minister must be impressed by that
johnson brass neckery
and the mood on the tory benches was
notably rowdier today last week's stony
faces replaced by loud cheers when the
prime minister arrived
yes
on the new look front bench some of
those hoping to replace boris johnson
can i say on behalf of the people of
redka in cleveland how grateful we are
for the support that he's given us can i
thank the prime minister for delivering
brexit and the fantastic vaccine rollout
program
can i thank the prime minister for all
he's done to help level up
stoke-on-trent i would like to first
send the huge thanks for your support to
ukraine boris johnson's due to appear
opposite starmah for the last time next
week but today a strange hint that this
could be his last pmqs the next leader
of the my party may be elected by
acclimation so it's possible uh this
will be our last our last confrontation
over this just
it's possible so i want to thank him
i want to thank him for the style in
which he's conducted himself i think
it'd be fair to say he's been
considerably less lethal than many other
members of this house
the loyally labour leader and the
unconventional boris johnson it is hard
to imagine two more different opponents
the noise was certainly back on the tory
benches today but the fight to save
boris johnson is over and labour may
well soon be facing a very different
kind of opponent
well we're joined now by two mps who are
voting for different candidates or have
voted already for different candidates
shall we say we've got anne-marie uh
trevelli and the former cabinet minister
who is backing tom tougan hat uh and
also of course
still current cabinet minister apologies
uh
and also justin tomlinson who is
supporting uh kemi and badanok and you
actually resigned from your position in
order to support um kemi badanok's bid
to get the job yeah and i was really
excited by kenya i didn't know her
personally i've seen her perform in
select committees into ministerial
meetings but she just had that ability
to engage to excite and you as a
journalist will know the frustration
when politicians don't want to answer
questions and with kemi she's willing to
challenge that consensus stand up and
just brings a bit of excitement back uh
to politics and as somebody who's
responsible for supporting our
colleagues ahead of their respective
re-election campaigns campaigning is my
thing
i think she offers us that best
opportunity to renew and secure that
unprecedented fifth term in office she's
done much in the way broadcast
interviews yet though has she but if we
can get her to those tv hustings at the
weekend and that was our aim and to come
to get those 40 votes to finish ahead of
some very strong candidates sawela and
tom shows that we are the candidate kem
is the candidate that has got the
momentum this is beyond our
expectations i'm very excited about what
this offers colleagues are queuing up to
come and talk to kenmi now they can see
the momentum um you uh backed uh tom
tugan had and some people would look you
know at your sort of record whether it's
on brexit or someone who i guess is a
forrest johnson loyalist in some ways
why are you backing tom tugan he's
saying he wants to offer a clean a fresh
start a clean start from boris johnson
so i'm backing tom because i think he
brings a real center ground nurse to
politics which i think is important now
as we go forwards as justin says the
challenge of winning historic fifth term
in two years time uh we need a prime
minister who's going to be able to
harness all our parties both talents
energies and cohesion so that we can
move forward and tackle some of the
really difficult issues that we've got
on our plate at the moment i'm
continuing to work on issues ukraine uh
whilst uh we go through this process
those important issues there the energy
crisis it's one that we have to tackle
tom has made uh if you like an emergency
commitment already that he would take
tempe off the uh
fuel duty for an understanding that
there is uh some really urgent uh issues
there that need tackling uh and i think
i genuinely believe he will be able to
cohere our party across the board so
that we can work together both at pace
and with some difficult decisions that
will need to be made uh in the coming
year uh it's interesting isn't it
because uh the fight
in many ways or on the kemi badalock
side on the right of the party the
pro-brexit uh wing of the party there's
quite a few candidates during the race
and yet can we battle you know appalling
of 40 votes today do you hope i guess
that some of the other people who may be
clamoring for the same vote such as to
allah rather than might fall into line
well i think what kami offered was that
ability to appeal to the broad church
that is at a certain party i'm not part
of any wing but what i want to see us do
is win that fifth general election what
we have to be focused on is there is
every chance we could hand the
government to a rainbow coalition that
is a very realistic prospect we've not
had a good
few months we've not covered ourselves
in glory comey is that genuine fresh
start that is engaging and is exciting
we saw this when david cameron for the
leadership we saw this even further back
with margaret thatcher that outsider
she's gone from a standing start we
didn't even have a website about 24
hours ago we're still designing the logo
ahead of the launch and 40 colleagues
have shown put their faith in her and
how other colleagues are queuing up to
have that conversation with him when
they do they will see how exciting and
engaging she is interesting i did hear
you say that you done beyond your
expectation did you think that she might
not actually make it this far well it's
very difficult
some colleagues are very they they guard
their uh which way they're going to go
wait to see which way the wind is going
to go the key for us was to get over
that 30 mark if you don't get to that 30
mark out you go and uh she's gone well
beyond that and i think of all of the
standout results nobody expected her to
do that well that's what creates mens
and that's what creates interest and
intrigue and then with kenny's ability
to engage i think we've got every chance
of getting it to the tv hustings at the
weekend the public will see what she has
to offer and that's where the momentum
will flow and tom tugan out on i think
37 votes so clearing the 30 vote uh
margin but i guess he is a bit of an
outsider as well i guess like kemmie
madonna too do you think he's going to
make it to the next round
so yes i have very confident that we
will do that and as uh
justin says colleagues are notoriously
both secretive and indeed fickle in the
way they use their votes in each ballot
they make a conscious decision
as they look at those who remain in the
race and they think about what their
both constituency issues might be that
they will want prime minister to
champion for them and indeed really
importantly i think for all of us and
every candidate
and every supporter
is the same which is we are very aware
that in 24 uh the risk of not being an
election means the risk of a rainbow
coalition for the country and that would
be a disaster now you've both given a
pitch for your candidates i just want to
have a look at the top uh echelons of
the race uh rishi sunak penny mordent
liz trust who do you think the momentum
is with i think it's comey i think it is
come on come on generally i've actually
departed
you've spoken about kenny with the three
establishments they were the established
candidates who have been well organized
for a reasonable length of time and who
blames them you know people are
ambitious i have no issue with that at
all but to go from naught to 40 from a
standing start without even a campaign
website shows that my colleagues are
excited by what she has to offer and now
she's shown she's a serious candidate
that's where the moment are you going to
answer the question who do you think are
out of the top three rishi cenac penny
mordent
and liz trust who do you think's got the
momentum well i think rishi is still the
one to beat but i think the reality is
that we will see all our all our
colleagues voting moving their votes
around over the next 24 hours again to
try and uh push those whose uh positions
are ones that they are closest down to
uh having perhaps shared their votes to
get their candidates across the line
today yeah interesting stuff i have to
say uh
quite a good to see kind of uh
colleagues i guess uh not tearing strips
off each other
whoever wins we've got unity i mean we
were we were both team boris
and we've got some fantastic talented
people in the party and whoever wins
they've got to bring the broad church
together are you a bit worried about the
tone of some of the debate some of the
briefings that gonna happen so this is
always a brutal fortnight the
conservative party uh has a brutal but
very efficient way of choosing a new
leader
we are all robust creatures
and we have an array of talent which
colleagues will choose and filter
through
and i have no doubt we will give our
party members uh two great candidates to
sign up on because we've got a
responsibility to govern and with the
immediate pressures of cost of living we
owe it to the country to get this sort
of quickly
do it in a united way one way or another
we will get there okay thank you very
much uh justin thomason uh and marie
trevelyan uh there a quick tweet to
bring you now this is a reaction from uh
suella uh brotherhood mp she's tweeted
to say thank you to my colleagues who
voted for me today i'm pleased to be
into the next round of voting hashtag
suella for leaders so ella brotherman
they're just clearing the 30 vote
threshold by just two votes in order to
make it into the next round of uh voting
um sam coats uh you are with us a deputy
political uh editor interesting here
hearing from the different mps drumming
up support for their candidates but we
are starting to see i guess some of the
front runners really starting to show
that's right there are two big
conversations going on at the moment who
are the front runners and then who
tomorrow is going to be uh knocked out
and you've got to look at the last two
on the list that just made it over the
hurdle tom toucan hat and suela
now both putting on uh brave faces but
in 24 hours time one of them is going to
be out of this race some on to tom
tokenhat's campaign suggesting actually
it would be quite wise for suella to
pull out this evening but there's none
of that talk from zwella braverman's
campaign
at the moment uh meanwhile at the other
end of the campaign rishi sooner penny
morgan and liz trust the conversation in
this room some surprise that liz trust
has not done as well as some had
expected given the scale expectation
around her campaign 50 votes a full 38
votes less than richard sunak suggests
that he uh is uh outperforming her uh
rishi tsunak now just 31 away from that
hurdle of 119 that you need to get in
the final
three the great wild card today the
great surprise in this race uh wasn't at
the cabinet table before penny morden
does she represent the kind of fresh
start that the leadership wants
and
is she the person who's going to take uh
everyone uh everyone forwards well
really interesting uh to talk uh sam
cape's there our deputy uh political uh
editor uh giving his view on the contest
and we are starting to see
i think uh some of the mps and really
pulling away from others rishi sunak uh
obviously at the top there on 88 but
second place penny mordent liz truss in
uh third well i think we can speak now
to steve baker
conservative mp a backer of
brotherhood she just limped